Prime Minister I mean clearly people of
Britain we're waking up to front pages
and wondering how this evil man slipped
through the security net how did that
happen well obviously the job that the
police and security services are doing
on a day to day basis is working up and
from all the sources getting
intelligence about plots being planned
and I understand that obviously they've
identified the two of the individuals
who were responsible for the horrific
attack that took place at London Bridge
but as I understand it they've said that
they had no intelligence that an attack
was being planned what we need to do now
of course is recognize that as the
threat evolves we need to ensure that
we're adapting our response to meet that
evolving threat so that's why I will
look at giving more powers to the police
and the security service longer
sentences for terrorist related offenses
dealing with this issue of the Internet
and ensuring there's no safe space
online for terrorists and dealing with
extremism online as well I think all of
these are important just must refer you
to the Foreign Secretary's words just a
few moments ago he said people are
looking at the front pages how on earth
can we let how on earth can we have let
this guy or possibly more through the
net what happened how can he possibly be
on the channel Paul program then
committing atrocities like this it's
fine secretary right about that well I
absolutely recognize people's concerns
we we want to stop attacks from taking
place we want to identify those who are
seeking to do is harm and stop them from
doing that harm over the last three
months we've had three horrific terrible
attacks in the United Kingdom we've also
seen the police and security services
foiling five other potential attacks
what we need to do now is to see how the
threat is evolving and it is evolving
we're seeing terrorism breeding
terrorism we've seen that tempo of
attack over the last three months we
need to ask how we need to adapt our
response to ensure that we can prevent
these in the future there's an issue of
adapting the responsible as an issue of
of record and it is the foreign state
himself who said that questions need to
be answered by mi5 and the police I
can't answer those questions now can you
and the mi5
mi5 and the police have already said
after the Manchester attack that they
would be looking and reviewing how they
dealt with that and I would expect them
to do exactly the same in relation to
London Bridge what government needs to
do and what the government that comes in
after Thursday's election needs to be
willing to do is to give more powers to
the police and the security service when
they need them needs to deal with this
issue of terrorism and extremism online
and also needs to be able to call out
and deal with extremism here in the
United Kingdom clearly the issue of
police cuts has been raised you've
recognized that police numbers are down
on when you became Home Secretary and
you've recognized also the armed police
were down and you changed you change
that now and now they're going up again
do you have any regrets over those cuts
and you feel that they might have
contributed in this case the community
reported this man what happened
couldn't cuts have had a role in this
man not being bought a book well we've
protected the counterterrorism policing
budgets we have funded an uplift in
armed policing and we have funded our
three agencies mi5 mi6 and GCHQ they
will have the money to employ 1,900 more
officers but it's also about the powers
that we've given to them I increase the
powers for the police and security
service when I was Home Secretary I
think that was the right thing to do we
now need to look at how we need to deal
with those powers increase those powers
further for our police and security
services for dealing with these issues
we always have to look at the threat as
the threat evolves we need to look at
how we need to adapt our response to
that threat it's exactly what I am
committed to doing but voters who are
going to the polls on Thursday will have
to ask themselves who do they think has
the commitment who can they trust to
actually say we need to do this we need
to deal not just with the terrorists of
course we need to deal with the
terrorists we need to stop these attacks
from taking place but
also need to deal with extremism in our
country and we've been too tolerant of
it in the past it does seem like members
of your government want to blame the
police blame mi5 blame Jeremy Corbyn
blame anything but the record of your
government the person responsible for a
terrorist attack is the terrorist what
we need to do what the police and the
security services are doing is working
day in and day out finding intelligence
from all sources to ensure that they're
able to identify when people are seeking
to do is harm we want to ensure they
have the powers to be able to do that
and to take the decisions necessary to
stop people from attacking us but we
also need to ensure that we are dealing
in this country with extremism we have
been too tolerant in the past is Home
Secretary I developed I published a
counter extremism strategy I want to see
people across this country recognizing
that the extremists are trying to divide
us and extremism can lead to violence
you promise difficult and embarrassing
conversations with no tolerance of this
intolerance but what about the Saudis
and this report that isn't been released
amber Rudd has just said we've managed
to reduce the funding and the links
between the Saudis and groups like
Islamic state have we do you recognize
tough conversations required with Gulf
nations tough conversations are required
with over this whole issue of financing
of the terrorists and the financing of
extremism with foreign countries we know
our line we need to we need to have
tough conversations with whoever we need
to have those conversations with you
called yourself a difficult woman in
relation to the brexit talks are you
difficult as regards the Saudis are you
difficult as regards to Donald Trump
insulting the Mayor of London a very
sensitive time I'd be very clear that
what Donald Trump has said about the
Mayor of London is wrong we worked with
Sadiq Khan in responding to this attack
he has been at the to Cobra meetings
that I've chaired the government's
Emergency Committee ensuring that
central government and the mayor of
London and city hall are working
together to get London back up and
running and people able to
on leading their lives as usual so I'm
very clear about that